we're experiencing these record brutal
temperatures because of human induced
climate change i know we don't want to
hear it but that really is what's
driving the hot weather that we've
experienced across western europe the
reason we've got the actual temperatures
of course is that we're getting the hot
air coming all the way up from the
sahara from north africa and it's just a
perfect storm of factors that has led to
the air being dragged all the way up
from the south to us and just all the
conditions the highs and the lows and
everything in the right places and what
we're seeing is temperatures of the like
of which we have never had in the uk now
i popped my garden thermometer just out
into the sunshine there i'm back in the
shade and you might just be able to make
out just towards the bottom left-hand
side the temperature already exceeding
40 indirect sunlight and the humidity
bottom right is very very dry and it's
that hot dry air coming up and you'll
notice of course that my thermometer is
already seeing over 40 degrees and
that's because when we talk about the
temperature on the weather forecast
we're talking about a temperature
measured in the shade and we do that so
we can compare like for like around the
world but when you measure temperatures
in direct sunlight well they're
obviously going to be much higher so
that's why it's causing so many problems
for um for the railways and your homes
get quite hot if you're in a car for
example temperatures get far higher than
that so the numbers we're looking at
today there is still a chance we could
break that record temperature today of
38.7 but i think we might end up
hovering at most around the 38 mark but
it's tomorrow when the heat really peaks
and that's when we could see 40 or even
41 celsius that's 106 fahrenheit we've
never had it in the uk and we're not set
up to deal with that level of heat here
people go abroad and maybe have
temperatures like that but we don't get
that in the uk and it's very unusual for
us to be seeing it and as we've heard
throughout the program it's a worrying
sign that we're seeing such high
temperatures